this is the first time in his words that
he's told an audience how he's feeling I
will give you a taste of what is quite a
long speech he says I must begin I must
say that I can only imagine what you may
have heard or perhaps read over the last
few weeks so I want you to hear the
truth from me as much as I can share not
supreme person that person that many of
you have watched grow up over the last
35 years but with a clearer perspective
the UK is my home and a place that I
love that will never change I've grown
up feeling support from so many of you
and I watched as you welcomed Megan with
open arms as you saw me find the love
and happiness that I'd hoped for all my
life finally the second son of Diana got
hitched hooray I also know you've come
to know me well enough over these years
to trust that the woman I chose as my
wife upholds the same values as I do and
she does and she is the same woman I
fell in love with we both do everything
we can to fly the flag and carry out our
roles for the country with pride once
Megan and I were married we were excited
we were hopeful and we were here to
serve for those reasons it brings me
great sadness that it has come to this
he then goes on to talk about how there
have been lengthy discussions about what
exactly what they wanted to do going
forward saying the decision that I made
for my wife and I to step back is not
one I've made lightly it was so many
months of talks after so many years of
challenges and I know I haven't always
gotten it right but as far as this goes
there really was no other option
you